Welcome to Ear Biscuits I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're asking the question how do you know
if you should throw
something away or keep it
because it has some sort
of sentimental value.
And I may or may not
well let's just say I may
be breaking out something
of sentimental value
value --
Value.
Value that I kept or at least my mother
my mother kept.
And I would say it may or
may not let's say may--
May.
Be an artifact--
From our friendship.
In first grade.
What first grade?
When we first met.
Who we kidding I know what it is but yeah
we're gonna break that out
and but you know what else
we're gonna break out?
We don't even have to break it out
because it has broken out.
Look at this Link.
Oh my gosh I'm--
Here it is.
The release of our novel "The
Lost Causes of Bleak Creek"
is upon us.
October 29th is when it comes
out and if you pre-order it
or have pre-ordered it
you'll be you'll be the first
to get it and read it
and then share in the joy
of us crafting this story.
Now when we're recording --
By experiencing the story.
Now when we're recording this
we actually just received
the final version of the book
in the mail and--
It's half shiny.
We were very very excited about was
the publisher asked us they were like
"Do you guys wanna do cause
there's like water on the cover
"do you wanna do like the water in kind
of a sheen gloss finish and then
above the water in like a matte finish?"
And we were like do we ever.
Yes 2019 baby.
It's funny because
that's not what we said.
I mean--
That's what I thought.
That's like you're
you're in marketing mode.
No I thought that.
And I'm very glad.
I thought that because I
had seen it on another book
and so as soon as there
was lots of questions like
you and CB were like
what does that look like?
This is the point.
Can we get some samples?
And I was like I seen it
and it's gonna be awesome.
Y'all can get your samples
if you want check it out.
This is my point Rhett.
My point is that--
Bam.
Anything that we get excited about
we also like at the same time
there's this like yin and yang
of it that's like well before
we actually all get excited
along with Rhett I wanna see samples.
Can you send us you know it's like--
Yeah.
I'm sure we
everybody we work with I
mean we're very collaborative
and we when we get we love to
get great ideas from people
but it's like it's also like
prove it because you know
that's why they have things called proofs
I live a sample-free lifestyle.
Not at the food court.
Well no
I only eat samples as an appetizer.
You know what I'm saying it's like
you want a free sample?
Yes not so I can figure
out if I'm gonna eat it
so I can eat more of it.
Sometimes I bet people
get frustrated working
with us because we're like
we can't just be excited
about an idea we have
to be like but also--
But now--
Let's have a proof
of concept and let's--
But we are now excited
about it.
Yeah now we're fully excited.
We got the endorsements on the back
and we've got pictures
of us and on the inside.
You know I mean I'm just so excited
when something becomes real.
Hold hold a piece of our
hearts by buying this book
and if you've already ordered one
order one for a friend if they
if they like to read books
or if they've never read a book either way
they're gonna love this book.
And on an upcoming episode--
BleakCreek.com.
Will it be the next episode
Kiko which we're gonna actually do more
in-depth explanation well
we're gonna explore the book
by kinda talking through some passages
and we're gonna get more into
the book as a whole podcast
but not only should you buy the book
because we think it's a great
story that you will enjoy
but you can also enter
your proof of purchase
at BleakCreek.com through November second
to have a chance to win coming out to LA
all-expense paid trip with you and a guest
to come and be a part of our
Bleak Creek Barbecue Bonanza
where we're gonna have a North
Carolina style pig picking
which incidentally is featured
in the first chapter of the book.
We're gonna recreate that.
Right here in Los Angeles.
Driving into my way this morning.
Void where prohibited.
I brought Jade--
No purchase necessary.
Full details at the website.
I brought Jade in to work
with me but the circumstances
Send her over Jenna.
Jade come here I'm talking about you.
Come here.
Brought in my doggy.
Brought in my doggy this morning.
You're gonna give me a little
kiss a little makeout sesh.
As you can see she's just as
she's just as happy or
really hard to tell as usual.
She's docile she's cool
she's calm she's collected.
But her mode of transport
was different this morning.
And my hand was kinda
forced you know this story
but I just wanted to bring
you guys up to speed.
Christy comes home this was
this is a little ways back
or maybe I came home from work
and she's like well listen.
Something something happened
I gotta tell you about.
I got pulled over.
I'm like oh gosh okay and then immediately
when Christy's like I got pulled over
I'm just thinking okay
I can't don't react.
Just be chill man.
It was probably all over your face though.
Just be chill it's like--
That internal conflict.
Like what why why should I react?
What is it about me that
makes me want to have like a
a lecturous or type of
response I guess is what it is.
Like well you should have--
And I'm like I just gotta
be cool be supportive.
It's not a big no matter what happened
it's not a big deal.
Obviously she's fine.
She's like it's actually
kind of embarrassing
and I'm like oh okay.
Now I'm intrigued.
Now I might have an Ear Biscuit story
get a little happier.
What life is about.
And she said "You know I dropped Lincoln
"and his friends off at the mall "
or actually another so another parent
dropped him off at the mall
so it was one of our
jobs to go pick him up.
She was like so you know
I went to pick him up
and I'm driving there and
I'm getting to the mall.
I get pulled over got
the blue lights behind me
and the cop comes up to the
window I roll the window down
Jade sticks her head out
'cause she was sittin'
in my lap and the officer says "Ma'am?
"I pulled you over because
your dog's in your lap."
Dom dom dom.
Ooh.
How embarrassing.
Now show of hands in our
small group that's in here
how many of you knew that it was illegal
to have a dog in your
lap while you're driving?
That it was a pull-overable offense.
A ticket-able offense okay.
I didn't know.
Three people didn't know.
If you had have told me
that it was a law I'd be like okay
I guess that makes sense but
I would have just thought
it was something that wasn't on the books.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And so Christy that was her response.
But it is on the books.
I didn't know he was like yeah.
This is not safe for you and you know what
it's also not safe for your dog.
I guess if like if you're in
some sort of an accident--
Airbag.
You're ping ponging
that dog oh yeah actually yes.
You know it's not cause
that by that rationale
you would need to put your dog
in a seat belt all the time
which I don't think is the law.
Mm but I think it's
probably safest for the dog.
Obviously obviously the
safest but if your dog
is in your lap
that airbag which can do damage to
and even kill a small child
is gonna do worse to a I
mean Jade is just gonna boo!
Which is why sometimes there'll
be a sign that comes on
in most modern cars that
says passenger airbag--
Off.
Turn it off.
Because the weight isn't
enough in the seat.
Right mm-hmm so if a kid's there.
Or if nobody's there you
don't need to waste an airbag.
Maybe that's also what they're thinking.
I gotta keep my airbag for later.
Probably not that's just how I think.
'Cause you can't repack an
airbag like a parachute.
I've tried.
Christy was like I didn't know.
And then he goes back with her license
and you know there's a sweat it out period
and at this point I was like
and were Lincoln and
his friend in the car?
Please tell me they were in the car.
She was like "No I hadn't picked him up.
"I was actually just around the corner
"from them being able to see
this whole thing take place "
which would have been glorious
for Lincoln's friends to
have to witness his mom
get a ticket because there
was a dog in her lap.
You know but I believe that the reason
that he believed her as she didn't
that he believed that she didn't know--
That's 'cause it was the truth.
Well no because the dog was in her lap
when he rolled the when
she rolled the window down.
Otherwise she would have been like
get into the passenger's seat.
Right.
So she played it perfectly
and she wasn't playing
she was just being honest.
Ma'am do you know why I pulled you over?
I don't know but you should ask the dog.
She's driving.
She's in charge here
because that's the thing.
He came well he came back
and he said "Ma'am I'm not
gonna you know I believe you.
"I'm not gonna give you a ticket."
So he didn't give her a
ticket picked up Lincoln
spared him the embarrassment.
Of course I'm not right now.
I hope all of his friends are listening.
What up fam?
Lincoln's dad in the house talkin' at ya.
I know how to connect with the kids.
Yeah you just demonstrated that.
Come over to my house
you can swim in my pool.
You can hang out you can play
music as loud as you want.
It can have profanity in it
because Lincoln's dad likes the hip-hop.
He's lit.
Can you imagine being my son?
Imagine it a second Rhett.
Um...
Oh you're getting a call from spam risk.
Yeah spam you see that?
Spam risk is calling you too?
You have a spam risk phone call.
What if your name was spam risk?
That would really suck.
I've noticed that my phone is just--
Messenger spam risk.
Please put me in your caller
ID as something different.
Here's the thing Jade is in control.
I mean let's be real.
When I drive in the car
and I'm seeing other people
with their poodles in their lap
and hanging out the driver
window I see it all the time.
You know every other day I'm driving
you see some poodle hanging
out a driver window.
And I've always judged
'em like that's stupid.
You're putting me in danger
putting yourself in danger.
Actually you're putting
your dog in danger.
Didn't even know that.
But then you know what?
I've been bringing Jade
I've been driving around.
She loves me so much I just
can't deny her being in my lap.
She climbs on over and she nestles down
but then after awhile of
that she started perking up
like perching up on my left
thigh and looking out the window
and I became that guy and she
started doing it with Christy.
It was partially my fault.
Hold on she's been driving in your
riding in your lap while you drive?
She's been steering practically.
Yeah she's like perched
up on my left thigh
which like my knee's kind of
up beside the steering wheel.
She's like right beside
the steering wheel.
And I'm like I became that guy.
Yeah you did.
So when Christy told me that
I'm like you know what
I know it's embarrassing
but I'm glad it happened
especially with you not getting a ticket
because this is a freakin'
wake-up call girl.
For both of us.
Because I haven't felt right about it.
I've just felt like I
shouldn't let my dog control me
rationalize oh she's so scared over there
in the passenger's seat.
But you know the reason
that you're the system
has completely changed in
the way that you're about
to tell everyone is because
your wife told the story
while the McLaughlins were with you.
Yeah we were on a double date.
And the McLaughlins buy things.
The Neals don't buy things.
Yeah so Christy tells this story
and we're in the backseat
and all of a sudden
like Jessie's on her phone I'm like
I mean that's a little rude.
We're kinda talking to you guys.
Why are you on your phone in the middle
of the conversation?
I didn't say that I was just like
before I could say anything and I'm sorry
for not giving her the
benefit of the doubt
she was like "Well I'm
on Amazon right now.
"I'm buying one.
"Because Barbara runs all around the car."
We're buying a harness for the dog
while they're in the--
Yeah I didn't say what one was.
And a seat harness for the dog.
But yes Barbara has been
in my lap while I'm driving
but Barbara is so gotta
be everywhere at all times
that she goes around the car
and then she usually ends up
laying in the passenger seat with me but--
Not with you by herself.
While I'm driving she's
in the passenger seat.
But it's still not safe
because she could fly
all over the car in the
event of a wreck or whatever.
So Jessie bought a booster
and so all the way home
I'm asking her I was like
"Read me some reviews.
"I don't like to look
on my phone in the car."
And like helping her find the best one
and then we found it and then she's like
"You want me to get you
one?" and I'm like "No."
I saw another one that is higher up that
instead of being a booster
seat it hangs from the top
and since Jade's smaller
this would allow her
to look out and I did run across that ad.
So I might do that.
And then she was like "Ooh I found it."
I was like "Well send me the link "
so then later that night I bought one
and it came in the mail and this morning--
This is like what 30 bucks or something?
They're not pricey.
That's right so this morning
was the first morning we had it.
I took a picture to send to Christy.
Look at her.
Look at her perched up there in a box.
This little carrier box
looks like something
like a basket you'd have
on the front of a car.
I mean a bike if if you needed
to transport ET somewhere.
Now can she just is she secured to this?
She is not secure.
She could top out.
There's a well if you look at this picture
you can see that pink thing
down there's a harness
she's not wearing it but ultimately
she's gonna wear her
harness and then it attaches
inside of this box but you
see how she's looking out?
She loves it.
She loves to look out.
But I'm trying --
Does she whine at you?
No.
She didn't whine like she
wanted to be in your lap.
Her ears went down a little bit at first
but then once she realized
she could see everything
she wanted to see she was pretty
happy which made me happy.
The plan is to put the harness on her
and then attach her to it eventually
but I wanted to do it one step at a time
get her more comfortable with it.
Look at her she's like
I might just give her her
own fake steering wheel
so she feels like she's actually driving.
That might be excessive.
Yeah well Jessie got one for Barbara
so as soon as Barbara
takes a ride in style
I'll take a pic.
Well I know something you don't know.
Jessie's already given
us that booster seat
because she tested it out with Barbara
and it was too small.
So now the other one
Jessie bought is now--
Is in Christy's car.
In Christy's car
and y'all and got nothing.
Well.
So you back to the drawing board.
Guess we gotta start over.
But yeah listen don't
rationalize having a dog
in your lap when you're driving.
I understand how difficult it is
but let's not be stupid okay?
I've been stupid and my
well I'm not gonna say
my wife's been stupid.
Let's just say--
that would be stupid.
You did things in ignorance
it's okay it happens.
Now you know and now you're adjusting.
Okay we're going to answer
some of your questions.
We like carrying on the conversation
keeping the conversation
going with the Mythical Beasts
and so we're gonna do that again.
But first we wanna let you know
that you can get a bunch of wristbands
and you can put 'em all
on one wrist if you want.
Yes Jade get up here.
If you have a small dog
maybe it could be a collar?
Maybe it could be a it's like a muzzle?
No no.
Muzzle?
You don't wanna do that because
that could be dangerous.
Yeah these are the Mythical wristbands.
Amongst other things they are
available at Mythical.store.
We got t-shirts
oh Mythical.com.
Why what is wrong with me?
See I'm still making I'm still
behaving in ignorance here.
Mythical.com.
Goes to the same place.
I mean it'll redirect so
technically not not wrong.
Yeah you can get all kinds of stuff
to make your life even more Mythical
and now your pet's life
even more Mythical.
We don't have a harness
or a booster seat yet.
But we've got a collar we've got a leash.
We got bowls we got a spill thing.
We got hoodies for pets.
You should be in a hoodie Jade.
We got all kinds of things.
Mythical.com.
All right.
I know we're gonna unearth this
the thing that you got
from our first grade year
with the subsequent question
but let's start somewhere else here.
This first question comes from Rayyan.
Should I pursue my
dream and take a program
I like in college knowing
that in the future
it might not exist anymore as a job
Oh.
Or go to a more guaranteed
option that I dislike
hoping that I'll take it later?
Did she say--
That I'll that I'll like it later.
College starts in a month
and I don't know what to do.
Okay it's a little late
cause I think college
has started now.
We were kind of sitting on this question.
Yes so--
But whoops.
I don't know what decision you did make.
Maybe she's undeclared I
mean if you're just starting
Ya you definitely can still change courses
Even if you've been in college a while
And maybe it'll be
applicable for other people
because the reason we wanted
to answer this question
is because we're actually
exploring this with our kids
I mean you've got a junior in high school
even closer to the point of decision
Ya.
I've got a sophomore in high school
and so I think one of the things that I've
done as a parent is I try to
think back to what my life
was like and the things that
were going through my mind
and what I was thinking about
life short term long term
when I was their age.
And then I'm like okay well
what would I like to have heard
from my parents at this stage?
And again it was a very different time
again the generations are very different
and I think that the amount of sort of
this may ultimately be
to our kids' detriment
but a lot of times the
amount of input and level
of discussion that we have about
all kinds of life decisions
I think tend to be more
involved and detailed
than it was with our parents.
I think as a cultural thing
it's also an internet age
thing there's so much information
out there that I think
so much more gets to us as parents
that impacts our children and vice versa
you know we there's a
culture of more conversation
that we have with our
kids than I than I think
our parents had with
us in that generation.
Ya because the nature of
the decision that we made
and I think it was very similar
it was very very simply we both
took physics our senior year
with Mr. Bryan and we
Ya.
And we didn't even do
that well in that class
I mean it was an AP class so whatever
it ended up being an A
whatever it was but I think
it was probably like a C
is what it technically was
but because it was like
weighted by 2 points
it ended up being an A.
But I didn't really understand it
I had to go to Michael
Juby's house for him
to help me do homework and
but because I liked Mr. Bryan
and I liked the concepts
that we were talking about
and the experiments that
he would do in class
I was like I should be an engineer
and I was good at math but
it was that simple but it was
My recollection is that
our guidance counselor
put that all together for both of us.
Oh you're good at math
you're good at science
you should be an engineer.
And I'm like my dad has always
been a fan of the wolf pack
that's where you go to
get an engineering degree
and it's in-state.
But it wasn't this like
have you been cultivating
or even exploring
Passions
Ya what your passions are and what it is
that you're good at and what
kind of gets your motor running
that wasn't at all what the process was
No.
Because if we had have explored what got
the motor running we
would have known that well
something creative.
Well and we were doing that
and we were talking about
you know we were writing screenplays
we were talking about being filmmakers
and we've oversimplified.
Your dad kind of exposed
and when we went back
to Buoy's Creek for the--
Ya.
For the Bleak Creek
documentary series that we did
Well it was actually so we--
Your dad kind of exposed--
We did interview at NC
State what really happened
we did an interview at
NC State that they put
into the NC State engineering magazine
and we told a greatly
simplified story that we've told
many times which is we
wanted to be filmmakers
we wanted to major in film
and when I told my dad that
he said "Well I'm not paying for that"
and so I ended up being an engineer
going to engineering school.
So I talked to my and I
truly believe that that was
the memory and I that
was how I remembered it.
Now when I talked to my dad
after that article came out
even though we've told
the story many times
he said "Now you know I was
kind of misrepresented in
"that article that isn't what happened"
and we didn't explore
exactly what happened
and maybe it was the
16 or 17 year old Rhett
interpreting something
concluding something on behalf
of my father that he didn't
actually say which is
"I'm not too excited about
that particular aspiration
"why don't you do something
that makes more sense?"
And it could've been
something that just emanated
from him without him
actually vocalizing that.
And now that I'm a father
I very regularly recognize
that I do the same thing
there's all kinds of messages
that I am giving to my sons
that I'm not saying directly.
But suffice it to say the
message that I sort of
understood was that you need
to do something that makes
some kind of sense.
And that scared us away from
the very open-ended insecure
not-guaranteed future
that was film making.
And now thankfully we've
made our way back into
using a very secure
What is it circuitous?
Circuitous.
Circuitous path to being
in a creative industry
and no longer doing engineering
but if we could go back
and talk to those high school
juniors high school seniors
who are trying to figure
out what they're gonna do
what do we say in terms of
how you make a decision?
In Rayyan's question it wasn't
made it wasn't specified
what the passion was and then
what the sensible option was.
It's a false dichotomy in her
question I will say though
because it's should I do something that--
Won't exist--
Won't exist anymore or--
It's like you wanna be a bus driver
Or should I do something that I--
Because they're gonna be autonomous.
Or should I do something that's guaranteed
that I dislike.
And I'm not really saying that
that's the false dichotomy
I was saying that the false dichotomy
is that you're choosing between
something that you like and
something that you dislike
I don't think it's that simple.
But ya you're also right
that you know you can't
predict what's going to
what's gonna be around and--
I mean you wanna--
And what jobs are gonna be around.
You wanna be able to support yourself
You know the nursing field
is it's funny I always hear
well the nursing field you
know there's always gonna
there's lots of opportunity there.
It's like but you better you
better be into helping people
and getting your hands
dirty to help people
if you wanna go into nursing.
I mean you gotta you have to find a way
for ultimate fulfillment to
believe that your passions
can be engaged in what you're doing.
I mean that's the challenge is
well I think the first challenge
is really understanding
your passions.
Something that I think
we were starting to do
but then figuring out the way to then find
the intersection between
that and there being
sensible components to your action plan
it's like okay I can
support myself someday
in something related to this field.
But I mean like--
Well I think you're actually
I think you're looking for
there's three sort of circles
Well what's the best thing
Circles that come together right.
There's the passion
And I think I read a book at one point
that outlined this but
I read this book too.
But you've got your
passion and then you've got
the sort of the practical
like what opportunities
do exist in the real world
and then you've got your
actual ability right
Ya
Because there's some people
that are very passionate
about something.
I want to be Bob Ross but
you can't grow an afro
Exactly what I was thinking.
You know hang it up.
So as you might be very
passionate about something
but you are actually not good enough at it
you're not pro--
so let's just go with another P.
You've got passion you've got practical
and you've got proficiency
I'm just making this up that's
not what the book said at all
and I'm probably wrong but
I think you've gotta have
some proficiency at this
you've gotta have some reason
to believe that oh I
actually there's a reason
that I believe that I
would be good at this.
And not better than everyone else but just
you don't wanna go into
something that you're just gonna
naturally be bad at.
I wouldn't there's a number
of things that I wouldn't
go into that I probably
wouldn't go into like a
hospice counseling as an example.
As an example right?
Because when people are going
through really hard stuff
I'm not the guy you want in the room
you know what I'm hopefully
getting better as I get older
but I don't have a natural
disposition for knowing what
to say when someone's having a hard time.
And so--
But there's a lot of money in it and so
you might want to think about it.
You know that's the sad
thing is there's probably
not a lot of money in it.
And so I think you've gotta
think about your proficiency
and passion and then what are
the practical opportunities
that you have.
And then you know what you gotta do
you've gotta develop a p-p-p-p
Plan!
Keep the peace going.
You know I really this is
one of those instances that I
where I really find myself wishing that
you that I wouldn't have
been blazing the trail
between the two of us.
You know I got married a
year before you which meant
I had a kid a year before you.
Like that's how the plan works right?
Lily's a year older than Loch
I really wish that you know
you guys could be the guinea pig.
I mean there's lots of
things that like you get
really engaged and you're
like thinking about
the way future and I've
gotta figure this crap out
and ya man I'm watching closely.
You're like talking about
when I get a TV and then
you get the same TV?
Yep yep.
It works differently
with children I believe.
That silver television
that we both had for years
Right because we are--
Because we both were at Circuit City
I was like ya--
Circuit City.
If you're gonna do that research I'm just
gonna swoop in and get one too.
I binged every episode of "Alias"
on DVD on that television
it was an old school tube television.
And then you got rid of it which takes us
to the other question later
but let's stay on topic for now.
So you are in the midst
of answering this question
because Lily's like she's like--
Lily she--
She's like taking the SATs
like this week or something right?
She's taking the SATs she's
taking the versions of the SAT
and the ACT for practice.
The last two weekends in a
row she spent three hours
taking both tests.
You know I felt for her.
You know what you're Saturday's gonna be?
Three hours of taking the SAT.
And then the next week the ACT.
And then figuring out I mean
you know we're fortunate
enough to have the means to
have somebody that helps us
navigate how you go about this.
And it's not just like the
counselor at the school
it's the people who will help
you take the practice test
and all that stuff.
Ya.
And there's so much
there's so much rigamarole
to go through--
And we don't--
And there's so much pressure.
Oh my gosh it's stressing me out.
The way this system works
It's stressing me out
just thinking about it.
The way this system works
right now and how things
are rewarded and the
competitiveness and how hard
let's just not let's just set that aside
cause that could be a whole
podcast in and of itself
the way the system works and how you have
to navigate the system.
If you're trying--
But what am I telling Lily
I think is the question.
Ya.
Right and what are you telling Loch?
I Lily is at a point where
she's still trying to figure out
what is she most passionate about
and what it's like I
don't expect her to have
a simple answer you know?
It's like honestly I mean
I don't I guess I haven't
told her this specifically but I think
my underlying thing and I
may have said this before
is that it just seems
like it's a crap shoot.
You know it's like you do your
best especially if you try
to figure out you know
apply as much of what we've
talked about with the Ps and then you just
rolling the dice man.
You're seeing what happens
and then you roll with it.
Roll with the roll the dice
and then roll with the punches.
She's like I'm really into
biology I think I'd wanna be
go into the medical field be a surgeon.
You know she had the spinal fusion surgery
had a huge impact on her life
that was a big life
experience that I think then
at least part of that and
then enjoying those classes
so we're like ya there's
and then we figure out
what would be the path
and what are the things
that she could do now
in order to position
herself to to get there.
Even things like okay
you can get involved in
this club at school which
then leads to an invitation
to this thing over the summer
that is by invitation only
that then when college
is who you know if you
wanna do the pre-med thing
ultimately so you get
back to those details
of the planning.
But then she comes home the next day
and she's like "I wanna
I'm really good at pottery"
That's a P that's good.
Ya it is.
Pre-med and pottery are both Ps.
Right and that's really--
So as long as it's a P.
That's our only requirement.
She's good.
And I find you know she's
engaging her passion for piano
she doesn't talk about piano as much
but it is a P.
But she comes home and she's
talking about making pottery
and like how much she enjoys it.
And you may say well
that's a good past-time
you see what I'm doing here?
But is it a passion.
And is it a p-areer.
And how practical is it.
Is it something you should pursue?
And it's imp-p-p-possible to figure out
by the time she's gotta go to college
and p-atriculate.
I don't think you're--
Get all this stuff straight.
You're violating all the rules man.
I mean I'm just like do the
best you can and be willing
to change at any moment or--
Okay--
Or maybe at certain intervals
like 6 months down the--
Intervals man take those now--
But I don't know I just
try to remove the pressure.
Let me---
There's so much my thing in summary is
I'm just trying to help
Lily understand herself
have as many opportunities as she can
and then develop a plan
but then remove pressure
I think is my main role at this point
is saying you know what.
I look at me.
Look at how I got to where I'm at.
It's I can't make a prescription
based on that you know.
Well yes so I think that
even more so for them
that will be the case right you know.
As time has passed people
that change their careers
are more likely to change
their careers even more times
over the span of their working life
than our parents were.
And then our kids are
gonna be even more likely
to change careers.
So the fact that we took
this crazy path to get where
we're at does really inform
the way that we think
about this in a lot of ways.
Oh ya.
I also think that me and
you as you know pioneering
as people might think that we have been
we are and we have tried
to discuss this before
we're actually pretty
reactive and we're very
practical and reactive and we
find ourselves in situations
and we're like oh there's an opportunity
there's some white space there.
And we can win at that game
let's go play that game.
And that's kind of what we've
done and it kind of indicates
why we've done a bunch of different things
and the path that we've taken.
And I do agree that you know
they're gonna go to college
and even if they end up
majoring in something
that is the career path
that they ultimately choose
they're not gonna really use
any of the things they learn
very little of it at least.
You know even going to
school for engineering
and then doing it
even with you you were
doing the co-op program
where you were working and
then going back and learning
you still learned your job on the job.
You learned how to learn you
grew up a little bit in college
but you didn't learn you're
not learning the skills that
what I'm getting at is the
college education thing is really
just a step in the
process and it isn't again
like you said you can't put
so much pressure on yourself.
But I think the real thing
that we're trying to do
is just position them for
a the most opportunity
that they can have right.
And just be like don't commit
to something because of
one thing that somebody says to you like
really just learn to
understand what it is that you
enjoy and what you're
good at and just know that
there's probably like a
whole category of jobs
that might work for you.
And that's the thing I've
been talking with Loch about
I'm like so you know not what
do you think you're gonna do
but what are you passionate about like--
Who do you think you are?
Is it working with--
Ask it that way.
Is it working with people
is it working with things
is it working with animals
is it thinking about ideas
is it executing things
is it a combination of those things?
Working with people dressed as animals.
Yes and I think that if
you can just ask yourself
those questions it'll
naturally sort of push you
in a direction where there's
a sort of field of jobs
so in ya know I think
sometimes it's like okay
some people are just like
I'm super into programming.
Like it's my passion it's what I wanna do.
Now obviously there's ample
opportunity for that skill
you can get a job doing that
so that question is answered
and also you kind of know
the different kinds of jobs
that are gonna require that skill
and it that's the kind
of thing that you're into
you kind of have a general path.
And some things are a
little bit less obvious
like pottery is a little
less obvious right.
You know like what are the
different opportunities
you can do with pottery?
Well you can be a person who makes pottery
You can be a person who
teaches people to make pottery
Right and that's kind of it.
That doesn't mean it's a bad idea right.
Maybe there's other things
but we don't know them
And you kind of have to know alright
I'm gonna go into this
basically what I'm really saying
is I like to do things with my hands.
I like to do physical things
I don't wanna be sitting
at a computer typing.
I don't wanna be doing a
bunch of math and processing
information but I wanna be
bringing something to life
with my hands.
I wanna be taking a raw
material and doing something
creative and artistic okay.
You're kind of pushing
yourself in a certain direction
and there'll be all kinds of fields
some practical some more
practical than others
that you can kind of then look at.
And that's all I'm trying to do with Loch
is just don't get too worried about how
I mean I want you to do
well but I don't want you
to be totally freaking out.
And trying to get into
some Ivy League situation.
Let's just take it easy
enjoy life do your best
but learn who you are and
then see how you can direct
that in a general direction
and then it'll start
getting pared down as the
opportunities line up you know.
And as you come to know your passions
be very attentive to that
don't check that at the
door when you're then going
in to make that practical decisions.
Ya.
It makes it more difficult
but the alternative
is an even more difficult
life of frustration.
Rayann good luck with that.
Veda asks "what color
should I dye my hair next?
"Done blue and purple so far."
And what I see in her
profile image her hair
looks like red but I
think that may be purple
Green
That must be purple.
Green another primary
color you haven't done yet.
Green.
Green and white ombre.
It's kind of like slimer vomit.
That unfolds over time.
Let's go with another one.
Okay let's get to this one.
Molly asks "I'm working--"
okay this is @Livyk_0620
I can see that she came to
an event and got a picture
with us because her profile
picture has us in it.
That's right.
"I'm working on an epic purge of old stuff
"Notes/books from college and grad school
childhood mementos, et cetera--"
Et cetera.
"How do I decide what to
keep and what to let go
"when I'm on the items that all
seem sentimentally important
"but intellectually frivolous.
"Hashtag ear biscuits."
Okay first of all girl
you're speaking my language
when you talk about an epic purge.
I you know I
I woke up this morning
on Tuesdays and Thursdays
I try to just take an hour to sit
drink my coffee try to
meditate a little bit
boy I talk about that a
little later it's not easy
and then I last 15 minute
Christy comes down and like
and you know we're having
some moments where we're
having our coffee together and it's nice.
You're like an old couple.
Old couple of moments together.
And I was like what
does your day look like
and amongst other things
she told me she was like
"I need to give Katie a call."
And I was like when you do
you need to take that mirror to her
and she was like "what's wrong with you?"
I'm glad somebody else
was asking that question.
She wasn't mean about it she's like
"I think something's wrong with you"
I was talking about there's
this big honkin' box
in our garage let's face it
my garage is how I look at it.
That's weird.
I look at the garage like
my domain it's also the
laundry room but hey
it's not a woman's job
my domain.
We both do laundry in there
but for some reason I
consider it my like mine
and I'm sure I've spoken
about it many times
just to keep it clean and
I'm like I'll take a picture
and then I'll spend
three hours purging stuff
out of the garage
and then take another picture
just to have another before and after
and I'll flip back--
You do before and afters?
And I'll flip back and forth
between the two of them
just to make myself feel better.
And I'll show it to
people if they come over.
I'm glad you've never shown that to me.
Well I'll show it to the
people in the video farm.
And I just flip back and forth
and it makes me feel good
and I've got this big box
and its got this big mirror
and they sent us two and didn't
want to return one of them
because we only ordered one.
For some reason they said keep it okay.
So I mean it's like five
foot by four foot box
five inches thick that's a lot
of real estate in my garage
and Katie's you know Christy
told me two months ago
Katie wants this mirror
don't get rid of it.
Ya I get this.
So this morning like I
think I'm calling Katie
and I'm like you should
take that mirror too.
She's like "I didn't even
say we were getting together
I just said I was just gonna call her."
I was like well tell
her to come pick it up.
[Rhett chuckles]
Like it won't fit in her car
and I'm like I'll take it out of the box
and then she can just have
the mirror because I bet
the mirror alone will fit in the car.
It's a big box it's too much padding.
She's not shipping it she's gonna tow it.
And at that point she's
like again she's like
"what's are you okay?
"That's not really what this
conversation was about."
Right.
So I actually feel like I
purge to a dysfunctional level
yet I'm also an archivist
of things that matter to me
and I feel like so I don't
feel like I'm healthy
but I feel like maybe I can help.
Well you know there's the whole--
That's where I'm coming from.
The minimalism movement
and what's her name?
Marie Kondo.
So every little shop you
go into in Los Angeles
there's a book by this woman.
She had a Netflix thing
that I did not watch.
Have you watched it?
No I understand and I
appreciate the approach
and of course all I know
about it is that you're
supposed to hold something up and then ask
if it gives you joy and if
it doesn't you get rid of it.
But you say thank you to
it before you give it away.
I don't need to read the books
I think I got the main message right.
Okay you sound a little
condescending in your tone but--
Well because my personal
opinion on minimalism
is that I actually I kind
of like a lot of like
you go into one of those
houses and like somebody
has put a bunch of stuff on the wall
and there's like stuff everywhere
now not disorganized not hoarder stuff
I'm not a hoarder and I don't like
I actually don't have
real hoarding tendencies
and I get anxiety when
I see things pile up
even though my wife might say "well you
"haven't demonstrated that at home."
You like art de-co-hoarder.
I wouldn't say I like TGI
Friday's and like what
they've done in there
because that's just a corporate thing
but you go into somebody's
house and they just--
It's like straw-backed chairs
hanging from the walls.
There's just something
comforting about like man
they've just got all this stuff
and they did it for a reason
even this right here like we've
got all these little things
All the knick-knacks.
It's just something
that Cassie put together
and then painted gray I've
never really studied it.
There's texture.
But it just ya it adds something.
Whereas when I think about
a super modern minimalist
house that doesn't have any place to sit
and there's nothing on the wall
I'm just like it feels cold and sterile
and so I feel like minimalism can at least
aesthetically can lead to that place.
But I do understand the
whole idea about like
if you got something in
your life that's just
kind of like creating
unnecessary clutter and time
and like it's a waste of time
and it's a waste of your
energy and your focus
then get rid of it.
And I do feel good about the
process of getting rid of stuff
But what is the connection between that?
Cause you're describing an aesthetic too.
I think what the question
what's behind the question
is more of like kind of more of a story.
It's more in the garage than
the living room mantle piece
type sitch.
You're by the way this
is you and Jessie must
be on the same page
because I would describe
how your house is decorated
I know she does a lot of
work on that and it's amazing
there's so much stuff
but it's all purposeful
like that you've got a whole wall
Ya.
You've got a freaking wall that's--
It's a shelf.
It's 30 foot tall it's
nothing but shelves.
We designed it together.
With stuff on it.
We designed that entire shelf together.
I think we're talking about
more in a storage capacity
So how does what you're
saying apply to that?
If you're getting rid
of stuff how do you know
what to hold on to?
I feel like this feels like
a very organic process to me
like when I am getting rid of something.
It's like I don't okay for instance
if I'm getting rid of clothes.
Well sometimes you've
had a shirt for so long
that it feels like it's
passed into some sort
of memento quality.
Oh I've got a couple of those.
You know what I'm saying.
And then I'm like don't you want--
Math olympiad shirt.
It's like and I'm not even
talking about like a child
obviously it's like stuff
that you at least had
from childhood you know.
And like okay I found a
wax paper dogs t-shirt
that Trent had designed the front of.
Oh ya.
And you know it was like oh I'm gonna--
You're talking like first
year out of college t-shirt.
Well I found a shirt that
said "Merrill rules the world"
that we had--
Spray painted?
Spray painted.
You know what I'm saying?
Like with stencil that we
wore to a concert I think.
I can't remember.
But like I'm definitely
not letting go of that.
We wore that to school on Twin Day.
Okay well I've got it.
And we both spray painted
"Merrill rules the world"
so we could be wearing
the same exact shirt.
There ya go.
See I'm glad I told you
because you remembered it.
But I have it.
I'm surprised you have it.
So you're always surprised
when I have something
because you think that
I don't hold onto stuff
and actually I do I just don't do it in a
I don't do it as much or
as intensely as you do.
Do you have a place?
Because my answer has to do
with place like storage place
Ya like most of the stuff
that is most of this stuff
like t-shirts and old
documents you can really get it
small and flat and so what
I found is that I just
have a place in my garage
I actually thought about
moving it and began to
move all this to my attic
recently and then I was like
in the case of a wildfire
coming into our neighborhood
and burning up our house
You can get that stuff out quick.
I think well I think that the garage would
actually survive because
it's below ground.
And I think that this stuff
the house the top of the house
would burn and all this
memento stuff would just
so I don't have to take it all out.
That's my theory at least.
So I have it all there
and it collapses down
and as long as it's not a big bulky thing
I'll get I will get rid of
something that is bulky.
But if it's something that
can be kind of folded up
and put into a box and then
I can put a label on it
and set it somewhere in my garage
and not have to worry about it.
Ya that's exactly me.
I don't go through this process of like
does this bring my joy?
It's like no I might want this later.
And I can make it I can get it
out of the way let's keep it.
There's mementos but then
there's there's things
like the thing that your
mom found that we need
to look at here in a second.
I that are irreplaceable I
mean especially if it's like
creations or somethings that's
and if it's irreplaceable
and it takes you back
and also second criteria
it can be stored especially
in like a reasonable
amount of space.
Like I got a filing cabinet
and I've got a couple of boxes
I've got an area where
like I'm willing to devote
this much storage space to keeping stuff
so that when I go through it
it's a journey back in time.
Or if I'm gonna write a
book like when we wrote the
"Book of Mythicality" when you
write a book about yourself
one day or share stuff
with your kids or grandkids
all that stuff you should
keep and you should be real
controlled on how you store it
and just keep it within certain bounds
like physical bounds.
But stuff that's like if you
start getting into things like
well so-and-so gave me this or
well first of all the easy stuff like
I might have a use for this one day
I think if it's been x-number of months
if it's been a year
and you haven't used it
I say get rid of it.
But if it's something that's like
so-and-so gave me this vase
it's not it's breakable
it's not easily store-able
but it does have some
sentimental value they've
passed away or whatever.
I think you keep it if you can
incorporate it into your life
if it's gonna be in storage
then I don't think--
I agree.
Then I don't think I think
you gotta either find a way
to bring it into your
life or you get rid of it.
If the purpose if it's
a piece of furniture
or something like that
the purpose of it is to
utilize it as a piece of
furniture or a piece of decor.
If you're not gonna
utilize it for that purpose
unless you just have tons of storage room.
Ya I say get rid of that.
And that's a point on
contention with my wife
because we do have some
things that we've received
from people there's like a lamp--
Never keep anything out of guilt.
There's a lamp that her
parents gave us that's
a really nice lamp that they
gave it to us a long time ago
and it's very ornate and
it doesn't go with anything
that we have.
She's just like we have to
hold onto that but how do I
it's just two parts and I just
I would get rid of that.
I would Craigslist that.
Ya you get rid of it.
Now gimme the story of this thing.
Because well this is a
good example of something
that should have been kept.
Your mom kept it and I'm so glad she did.
My mom gave me a bunch of
stuff you know years ago
that was we had she had kept in my closet
in my in the house where I
grew up in my personal closet
and then she gave it all to me.
And it was pictures and it
was schoolwork and it was
a lot and some of that stuff you know
a good amount of that made it to the
"Book of Mythicality" as well.
But then there was an additional folder
that I had somehow separated
from everything else
and it was in a closet that
then Jessie recently cleaned out
and then she found a folder
that has multiple things in it
but I'm just only gonna focus on the one
we can get into the other later.
But she found from first
grade in Ms. Loxleer's class
which was of course the
class that we met in
a Thanksgiving recipe book
and I'm gonna go ahead and
warn you that we all had
to design our own cover for this
and again just keep in
mind I was 6 years old
and it was 1984
so do with that what you will.
It was a Thanksgiving
book and so as you can see
I put a Thanksgiving theme
picture on the front of it.
So on the left you've got a pilgrim
and on the right you've
got a Native American
with his arms outstretched.
Yep.
He's much bigger.
He's got an egg for a head.
I don't have any explanation as to
any of the choices that I made and I'm not
going to defend them.
Why is that the posture
clearly unintentional posture
of the pilgrim and the like the snicker
I was just--
on his mouth.
Like he's snickering.
I mean don't read anything into it.
I know you wanna read
things into it but don't
because there's nothing to be read into it
but what there is to be read
inside of this book Link
is that every single member
of Ms. Loxleer's class
had to submit a recipe
that they would enjoy
for Thanksgiving.
And then she Xerox-ed them and put them
in everybody's book.
So for instance it's you
know you got David Rodger's
who incidentally made it into
the "Book of Mythicality"
as well.
He put Nana's turkey dressing on there.
But let's see.
If you get to Hamra's and
Maurice Cameron's oyster
dressing for turkey.
Christy's aunt makes that.
I hate it.
Somebody did cornbread
stuffing but they didn't
put their name on there.
Loser.
Anya remember Anya?
No.
Neither do it.
It's a recipe from Scotland though.
Oh Rhett McLaughlin Rhett McLaughlin.
Rhett McLaughlin.
Bleu cheese broccoli.
This is classic.
I wish you would've--
but it but it was when you
first told me about this
you were like you told me the premise
but you didn't tell me the recipe
and you were like you have
to guess what it was and--
Now again this wasn't
necessarily what it was
it was like I mean I
really like this of course.
Bleu cheese is a strong
thing and it's like you love
bleu cheese now.
Ya I do.
So it's like it was very easily
guess-able knowing you now
but it just seemed very surprising
cause it's like at that age you also--
First grade.
Liked bleu cheese on your broccoli?
And it was also you know I'm asking my mom
I'm like mom I need a recipe for this book
and she tells me you know--
But you must have really liked it.
Oh I'm sure I chose that I did
I specifically remember
her bleu cheese broccoli.
I don't think she makes it anymore.
They tell you how to tell 'em
how to prepare the broccoli
It's got margarine in it.
Bleu cheese.
And margarine is very 1984.
And then sprinkle with what?
Cracker crumbs.
At the end oh ya you got to get that
cracker crumb game cooking.
Bake at 325 for 20 to 25 minutes.
It serves six to eight.
Which means it serves four McLaughlins.
[Link laughs]
Alright so I'm in here right?
So if yours is classic Rhett bleu cheese
the question is is mine classic me?
Well yes it is.
Is the me now the me then?
Link Neil chocolate peanut butter balls.
Yes.
I mean I don't know why I'm surprised
but it's strangely validating
that like the things
that matter most about me haven't changed.
I love peanut butter.
Now I hate to do this to
you but I will say that
Adam Nicholson just did
peanut butter balls.
So he had actually--
It's a page before me.
Ya well cause ya it's a purer recipe.
And you had to add chocolate to yours
which is a little off-brand might I add.
I like chocolate
I love chocolate and
peanut butter together.
But ya he--
The other thing that's a
little bit off-brand is--
Makes 150 balls.
That's a lot of balls.
What is that that I drew at the bottom?
Looks like salt and pepper shakers.
I feel like I'm surprised that our recipes
like they're pretty similar
in their presentation
and like you know I
would've thought that mine
would be really difficult to read
and hard to follow and not well organized.
But they're basically very similar.
Like we both--
Well our moms wrote them and
then we just copied them.
No no but if you look
at these other recipes
like we both made a very specific choice
that no one else made.
We put a line at the top we
put the recipe name at the top
and then we put a line and we
put all the recipe ingredients
on each side of the line.
And then we put the instructions below it
like a cookbook.
We have very similar formatting instincts.
Naw but you put Link Neil
at the top and at the bottom
you wanted to make real
sure that everybody
knew that this was your recipe.
Oh yes.
Which that's on-brand as well.
150 balls.
And then we drew at the bottom
I don't really know
why I mean that doesn't
look like broccoli at all.
It looks like a bunch of
people on a boat sausage.
It's shaped like a piece of bread.
Now so to go back to the question
I mean I'm very grateful
that you have this
this is evidence of like
what our palettes were
I mean we make a living
someone could argue
just by eating.
I mean if we weren't able to
eat our careers may be over.
Now that's I hope that's not true
but some people might could argue that.
Eating food is a huge part of what we do.
And the success of where we are
Good.
Now but without this artifact
I wouldn't have been able
to definitively tell
you especially for you
because bleu cheese that there
was something there all along
ya you might would've told me you know
couple coffee need these
you might would've told
me but there would've been
a doubt in my mind.
That I liked bleu cheese?
Ya there would've been
a little bit of doubt.
It's like I don't know
with that age first grade?
You liked bleu cheese I don't know.
Ya I liked it the first time
they ever let me taste it.
But there's no doubt because
there's the artifact.
Cause your mom kept it and
now you're gonna keep it
in that place in your garage.
And that's important.
So Molly to answer your question
I think that these things will
I don't think it's about
looking at them and asking
if it brings you joy or
even saying thank you to it
I just think that you know in your soul
when you you know in your soul if you need
to hold onto something.
Unless you're a hoarder and then you think
you gotta hold onto everything
and that's a problem
you need to have addressed.
But I'm just saying if you
don't have that problem
if you can practically
find a way to store this
not an inconvenience to you
or the people you live with
I say hold onto it
because you might need it.
Especially if it's got some
sort of sentimental value.
If it has no sentimental
value and then you're
simply asking the utilitarian question
I might need to use this at some point?
Follow Link's rule and if
you haven't used it in a year
definitely get rid of it.
And if you need a mirror
like I got I got one for ya.
Like it's if you get it you'll know I got
the same one in my house
cause I had two of 'em.
So hit me up hashtag ear
biscuits if you want my mirror.
Actually don't I'm just being facetious.
Do you wanna--
Kate Katie's gonna get it.
You wanna hit this question quickly?
No I think that--
You wanna save this question?
I wanna save this question
it opens up too much.
Instead I'll just give a rec.
Okay.
Cause it's time to check baby check baby
rec two three four.
My recommendation it would've
been better to go with
last week's but it was your
turn to give the recommendation
and we have rules here ya know.
Without rules we descend into chaos.
We alternate who gives the recommendation.
Now if I would've mentioned
it because this is
a camping related recommendation
if I were to have mentioned it in my story
then you would've had the ability
to steal my recommendation
but I didn't mention it
because I wanted to protect
it from being stolen by you.
I'll have it on the record I'm not ever
gonna steal your recommendation.
I would never and you know what
I would never do that to you ever.
I would like to highly recommend a book
called "Second Mountain".
[Rhett laughs]
Come on man.
It's I haven't started reading it yet
but Rhett was telling me about it
my recommendation on
the heels of last week's
camping and VR conversation was and is
if you're gonna go camping buy
yourself a camping hammock.
Having gone camping a whole lot and then
falling out of it like I said
I was like the kids are
going they're excited
I really want this to pay off
I wanna validate their
decision to go camping.
And I need a little
something extra this time
a little something to get 'em more excited
and so I bought a camping hammock.
One of these hammocks that you
string up between two trees
and it's like very
lightweight and packable.
I'll recommend the Eno is the brand
E-N-O let's see I wrote down
it'll hold two people it's
called the double-nest.
You can get one that's
called the single-nest
just holds one person
but this one holds up to 400 pounds.
Did you sleep overnight in it?
No I took it out there the kids loved it
they could get in it it
was kind of like a swing
it was something to play in.
If you don't find two trees
that are far enough apart
like I drove the FJ over
but far enough from one tree
and then I you gotta buy the straps too
and I recommend buying
the straps that have
like multiple places that
you can hook a carabiner
instead of one.
So for about 110 bucks
you can get the hammock
and the two straps with
multiple carabener locations.
I hooked it up to the
top of the FJ and a tree
and like they were swinging
from that and having
a grand old time man.
I was validated.
And then you know what
and then aesthetically
this isn't working Christy doesn't love it
but out there on the pergola
I string that puppy up
and I've been lay I've
been swinging in a hammock
back there in the backyard
on my like I'm camping.
Have you taken a nap in it?
Oh ya.
It kind of bends you up a little bit.
All the blood pools in
your in your buttcheeks.
Well you know I read
about these cause I was
gonna get one for a camping trip.
And for like a solo camping trip.
And you're supposed to
well some of the designs
in order to prevent that from happening
you're supposed to sleep
at an angle that prevents
and I don't know if this
happens with every design
you sleep at an angle so that
you're not bending like that.
Ya.
So that you're straight.
Ya and this one will hold two people.
That's really interesting to try.
So like Lando and I get
in together at the house
and you know it's fun you can
read a book take your laptop
out there and watch some stuff.
But ya if you sit kind of
sideways that does help with that
and it's as it's getting
cooler I don't know how
it it has a real cooling
effect because it's so thin.
Well you put your sleeping bag in it.
You would have to put
your sleeping bag in it
and you would still get cold
you gotta watch yourself.
Cause you got nothing underneath.
Yep so I don't know about
sleeping in it overnight
in a cold environment but
boy it just breathes new life
into your camping experience.
And so I highly recommend
getting yourself a hammock.
String it up at home.
But if you get yourself a
hammock and you don't use it
for a year get rid of it.
It's stuff-able it gets
down to be this small.
Okay put it with your
other love-able trinkets.
Ya well you know--
Put it in put it up on
a shelf in your garage.
Put it with your camping gear.
Maybe you'll use it again you know.
I allot a certain amount
of space in the garage
for my camping gear.
I got some Tupperware associated with that
and you shove it in there.
Until next time may all
your hammocks be in use
and all your trinkets be stored in a place
that won't burn up in a fire.
And your passions engaged.
Hashtag ear biscuits.
Let us know if you agree or disagree
or if you can sprinkle some more light
on what we discussed today.
We would appreciate it.
Well I'm glad that you listened.
That's a relief.
To watch more Ear Biscuits click
on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on the circular
icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.